- Put it down, put it down Ryan.
- I just want to try it.
- Ryan put it down.
Ryan put it down.
- So, today we have these
little kitchen gadgets
and we are going to try and match them
to the correct item on the table.
- These are like crazy food products.
- Yeah, what object is used on which food.
- There's a lot of phallic
and non-phallic objects.
(laughing)
- Okay.
- This looks like it's.
- Doughnut.
- For a bagel but we don't
have any bagels here.
- It looks like there's a
cylinder, something circular
goes in it, so that narrows it down.
- Put it.
- Oh, this feels so odd.
(laughter)
- I think I got this right away.
- Please do.
- Okay, you know how it's so hard
to get the cob off of the corn.
You just put it here and you cob it off.
- I don't think that's right.
- This way, like.
- Oh.
- Well, if this is not what it's for
then I'm a genius.
- Whoa look at
- Oh my God.
(laughter)
- What is that?
Is it, oh?
- You know when it's really hard
to dunk a cookie because you don't
want a dunk the whole thing.
Well now we've got the cookie dunker.
- Kay, let me see.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
- What?
- That seems like a horrible, horrible.
- Is this hard boiled?
- Ray, put it down.
Ray, no, no, no.
(laughter)
- As a spoiler, it kind of looks like
somebody already cracked an egg in here.
(laughter)
- Oh, what does this do?
- Well now we're gonna
be adding grape in here.
Alright, let's find out, oh.
- Oh.
- Oh that did it.
- I mean it did slice a
grape into small amounts.
- That what it's for?
- What the, why would you slice
a grape like that though?
I've got a lot of
questions about that one.
- It would make a lot of sense.
- Same thing, pirate.
- Yeah.
- This is full blown pirate.
- That's what it's for.
I figured it out, I can go home now.
- We win.
- I did it.
- I have nothing.
- It's like captain.
- Pick your teeth with it.
- But I think it might be for the Oreos.
- Oh, to dunk it.
- Yeah.
- Whoot, whoot.
- That, that is what the cookie dunker is.
You're so wow.
(scream)
I'm happy.
- You're gonna try it, oooh she.
- No.
- Oh no.
- You're gonna use it maybe once and then
lose it and then for
the next time you have
Oreos you're gonna be like
man where's my Oreo dipper.
- Is this suppose?
- Oh well I'll just use my hands.
- Okay.
- They look like beautiful jewelry.
Like ear rings or rings or something.
- What if, go with me, you put mustard
on this one and you
put ketchup on this one
and then you like slide
it down the hotdog.
- Okay, the bigger one I guess.
- Hotdog spirlar.
- I don't think this is, is this correct?
This doesn't seem correct.
- I'm just like.
- Why would you want
to spiral your hotdog?
- If you have kids and shit.
- Then this hotdog is cut for the kid.
Look at that, that is, is that right?
- I would rather have it on like a.
- Wait, this is kind of working.
- Like a spiny thing and then just have
the knife like this.
I'm an inventor now.
- We made a mess.
I think the one thing we did here today
was literally, completely make a mess.
- You need to do that.
This is why I don't cook.
And this is why I don't have kids.
(music)